my great-grandfather was murdered in the
Holocaust more specifically Babi Yar
now nobody ever really talks about Bobby
are and most people don't even know what
it is that's why I want to share this
story so that the history isn't
forgotten
Bobby art is a ravine in Kiev Ukraine
it's 150 meters long 30 meters wide and
15 meters deep that's all it is
was normal regular stream OPA - all
units such the cone if I kill in your
videos etcetera rate is uber yet
asparagus why Russia by the way we have
deal anymore
you knew you were relative Arab unity we
know Zidan given the rights of enemy at
ski stick he had yellow monastic yet
that stearic Amazonian you Brazil sir
taken aback but that was a pleasure
what Academy females especially Strigoi
if so much upon you'll actually sleeves
and much marriage the Nazis occupied
Kiev on September 19th 1941 and six days
later September 26 they decided to
exterminate all the Jews in Kiev they
put out an order that said all hoods of
the city of Kiev and its vicinity must
appear on Monday September 29th by 8
o'clock in the morning at the corner of
Manitoba and dr. day of ski streets
bring documents money and valuables and
also warm clothing linen etc any kids
who do not follow this order and are
found elsewhere will be shot this was
one of the largest single massacres in
the history of the Holocaust in two days
over 33,000 Jews were shot and killed I
took my mom and my grandfather to
Ukraine to see Babi Yar and they
couldn't believe their eyes they lived
in Ukraine for years and had no idea
this place still existed
I just need service
what's crazy is this doesn't sound real
to me things start to just seem like
numbers or facts rather than real things
that actually happened so I decided to
do my own research and actually listen
to people who survived this terrible
event though cannot reduce pressure with
me on social good that is a loogey
booted was booth will visit with um
booty rich was brutally was it yourself
he would partially die if the kya no
kaliesha selenium so eager at what
sadhana story to dust cloud the rich of
Serie A Wish Yin Yin naturally very
vital was all that is not it a say that
the meniscus on guitar and watch zubarev
a lady Kerwin keep Zobrist a Libra sorry
Charlie still advanced it's about
causality minimal homey touches you is
he missing its terror strengths ego
Briatore as devout so don't use
nuobiniya when you Tony to inspiration
neato bad for the drug bruiser oh yeah
without you - you ain't see no more
through every a coup and they need
monkey magic go deliver you
mo means our selves used no guru Natural
History let you just study package via
Ron Paul Papa yeah we did like a couple
Polly personal mama Savoy but those just
refer to me I was in a porn you yeah you
put me at okay this last said yeah the
duck under the lordship of the hall at
notes yet hold this life scene and
amiability artist Josh's spell Shia yeah
they're not saying about like judges
through them
[Music]
yeah that you're gonna go with me on on
building mr. numb yeah but let y'all
just see my act y'all just see wasn't
the Sheila
unfortunately my great-grandfather
wasn't one of the people who survived
but I'm gonna make sure his story lives
on so here it is my great-grandfather
was serving in the army when the Germans
invaded he decided to come back to Kiev
to make sure that his pregnant wife was
okay when he got there she was gone he
didn't know that she fled he also didn't
know that his neighbor who he lived next
to his entire life ratted him out to the
Germans so the Germans came and forced
him to march to Bobbie our were they
undressed him made him stand on the
ledge fully naked and shot him and
that's it after the war was over my
great-grandmother came back to Kiev with
my grandfather and he actually ended up
becoming friends with the neighbors son
this whole event was completely brushed
under the rug nobody was talking about
it the Soviet Union was actually
thinking about building an amusement
park on top of the ravine it's hidden
inside a park and if you step outside of
the forest kids are running around
riding their bikes families are having a
good time they have no idea what they're
standing on so this whole story and
experience taught me how easy it is to
forget and when you do for yet it'll
happen again that's why we can't just
stand by and watch when people are being
killed or hurt or persecuted against we
need to have a voice speak out be
passionate because the opposite of love
is indifference
[Music]